où va l'argent pendant un transfert
bancaire quand votre banque reçoit votre
instruction et retire le montant prévu
de votre compte la somme prend le chemin
d'une sorte de compte de transit un
registre ou se retrouve tous les
virements demandés par les clients votre
banque va procéder ou vérification
d'usage notamment pour s'assurer que les
transferts d'argent sont pas frusuleux
ou que les comptes débiteur ont un sol
suffisant ce registre est ensuite
transféré à une chambre de compensation
et de règlement ce mécanisme là c'est la
colonne vertébrale des échanges d'argent
au pays et c'est la responsabilité de
paiement Canada c'est par la suite que
le compte vers lequel vous transférez de
l'argent sera crédité du montant voulu
le processus complet peut prendre
jusqu'à 24 heures ou plus si vous faites
votre transfert la fin de semaine ou un
jour férié chaque jour
476 milliards de dollars sont échangés
entre les institutions financières
paiement Canada travaille à
l'élaboration d'un système de paiement
en temps réel qui va permettre
d'accélérer ses échanges